[Music]
hello everybody
and welcome to a different
view for chess and psychology i remember
we had this
this view when we started this class and
then we moved it up wrote it down
moved it to pishi's place and we're back
here
so hopefully we'll keep moving it around
or we can have a fun pet the cat
segment bring in the pc see how many
viewers will come for the cats
all right so as we all know right now
the world cup's going on so we got a
bunch of
these super gm's trying to
win a lot of money and get into
candidates
and if i'm not mistaken uh this is the
first
world cup for women that's going to
have the same format as for men so
usually
for men like the winner i think that the
final four
or eight i think it's four usually gets
selected to
playing the candidate and then the
winner of that he has to challenge
magnus
it's four right that was the final two
and then the other is quality you just
found out the world cup yeah yeah
it could be two i could be hopeful over
here uh but yeah so a bunch of them
four to something gets qualified they
they get to um play uh
the candidates and i pretend they're
they're they want to do the same for
women which i think is kind of cool
because
before that women always had like two
different world champions so we were
like
well who is the queen now so yeah now
it's getting a little bit more cohesive
all right so for today um
we're going to take a quick look at a
game between
orientary and fioruzu so they're both
like persian blood so i think it's fun
but i
again please correct me because i have
my facts but i'm always wobbly on them
there's so many facts up here um i'm
pretty sure if you
just switched flags to french recently
officially
because i know the u.s kind of wanted
him for a while and then i
well i guess that didn't happen but yeah
so i know he's living there so it's kind
of good to
see he finally has a flag that he's
proud to represent
and arientari is also norwegian he's
always been
norwegian but all right so uh
one more tiny fact this is from
the the game that i'm going to show you
is analysis by my brother
borna who is going to play tournaments
soon i see pretty panicked about it
but um he did the analysis for the book
that we wrote together
so this is from a chapter uh
ergo the name of the title here turn
water into wine
i'm not a big fan of wine but people
like it so
all right so um this was
a very fun game because i also
think that carmichael opening is so
weirdly cool
i play that only a few times why is it
showing arrows i
dude no errors how do i stop the errors
here
arrow use
no i don't want the evaluation oh there
you go i
enabled the whole thing there we go
lovely no more hints
uh yeah so i think it's very interesting
because
when i play takara khan i only play this
few times and
i destroy it how did this go for you
no i've never played it you never play
tarot yeah it's so
weird like sometimes if i if i have
um yeah if i have a good the
like rubber tour and i know like what's
gonna happen
that's fine but i remember in the game
that i played i got completely
destroyed the one only federated
karakan that i played um then yeah it
was like i died my king was in the
middle of the center i couldn't get my
bishops out
ah all right
oh fishy waiting behind the window that
sounds quite accurate yeah he
does that when i'm not in the room all
right so
um this was
yeah uh so
i just kind of wanted to get a little
bit more info on how you guys feel about
kyrokum
so my neck is going to keep turning back
and forth
no it's not about you like i have to
look at this and the camera is there but
my chat is over here
so you're good yeah it's my neck workout
yeah i agree it's kind of solid but
oh god
whoops no i got over excited about
karakan all right whoa let's just keep
going
i shouldn't talk about caracon this much
coconut is not meant for this much
discussion
so um we're finally getting to one of
the main positions
what i wanted to mention before i got
here was that i
play like this weird little knight d2
idea that i
would like you take i take and i don't
want to make the center as clear as when
this game happened so i just wanted to
uh point out
that um that's something you guys can
just
consider exactly i'll start choking on
karokens
maybe we should change the title all
right so
so that's kind of where we landed here
so
i just want to get a super quick
basic idea of how do you think we should
develop
which pieces are going where i don't
play this often as black i
actually barely put this as black so
yes it is karakan
hello this is not a game from the world
cup because
um if you've seen me streamed before
i purposefully ignored the games of the
week
because i find it that every single
streamer and every single like
instructor
with online is usually just talking
about that
event going on so i tried to go a few
years back
and pull a cool game
something to g5 ah
so uh so the the biggest problem with
like the karaoke on french stuff
is this this bishop right so if this
bishop currently
is not under much problem
and it has an open file open diagonal
bishop don't need open files
then we should be using that so what do
you think the move should be
and for those of you who know the
opening good for you everybody should
know the main lines
of every opening just for like the first
10 move that's something that's
uh rest in peace uh louis kavinas used
to say
but if you want to be a good chess
player you got to know the
main lines of every like every opening
for like the first hand move to just
note how the pieces get out
so i agree that uh we so we want to get
this bishop out and then we want to get
this that
i miss my mouse and then we want to get
this diagonal
so we got to get this bishop out so we
can then play e6 and get this
stuff in the diagonal so
knowing that let's just go ahead
yeah so
we definitely do want to strengthen this
pawn
as well and it's a better idea to just
have your bishop out rather than trying
to
figure out thank you
rather than trying to figure out
where do i put this
oh there we go i think so
yes and it works perfect
why not envy your job too many cables to
set up
yeah all right i completely like this so
bishop g4 idea and now
should whites try to do the same thing
with queen c2 or
is b3 the square to go for the queen
mouse p she would be jealous now fishy
has been feeling a little weird
in the last day or two doesn't want to
play as much
so what do you guys think
um yeah exactly queen b3 is the better
one queen city is definitely possible
too
but squishy you're not really
threatening anything
and i would simply just
bring this knight out and
just follow normally like get the rook
rolling
get the rook rolling
and like black has such an easy
development
so yeah let's continue but the reason
that
i don't play this line as white there's
nothing wrong with this line but
i like to make my opponent as miserable
as possible and right now black just has
a very
easy development and i don't like that
about it
so like it's black has a very easy time
finding square source pieces whereas in
like the knight d2 knight c3 lines when
the knight is on e4
it's a little bit more complicated but
again this is in high level chess
so everybody knows like everything about
theory so
that's um not that this is a trickier
opponent in the opening as i like to do
so um
mimi i'm not sure why are you so fixated
on g5
even if it's like h6 g5 i don't get it
you worry planning to where you're gonna
do with your king
so let me ask you uh how do we like the
knight d7 idea
what do you guys think about this
yeah i agree a little bit risky because
the main thing to answer is what if i
lose this pawn
then what would you do
hi manny i agree i kind of like queen c7
more too
yeah exactly hold on what do you think
we should do here
um just
just e6
a little short
oh we should play yeah
so e5 is the best one and the idea is
after tank i take and
i have some counter but i mean black has
good piece activity but it's hard
to feel great about your position
because for example right now this this
move doesn't work you just lose the
other pawn
and if you bring the other knight
it's still not great because you just
you you just went you just
got your night activated so if you have
to come back it doesn't really
um make as much sense
yeah for a price of the pawn i would
want more honestly
so yeah i wouldn't give this pawn up but
if you're playing blitz and if you want
to make kyrokan all spicy and sharp i
guess that's one way to do it
but i like queen c7 more uh are you new
and for h3
let's get the bishop back in this place
now tell me why not
bishop h5 which was 5 is not necessarily
a bad move
but why do you think it's not as
pleasant ah no stop showing me no
bad mouse
yeah this works better there i think
white can play g4 yeah g4 is
it already has a kingside attack yep
g4 is a little concerning because after
g4 you got to move the bishop
and take you'd have to take with h
then it's just a little like extra
unnecessary unpleasantness
and it's not like you're losing right
now but it's just
why would you make the game inconvenient
so we don't want that we want to be able
to
keep the game spicy
so now is it time to give up on this
bishop and play e6 or can we try to
let it breathe a little longer
i'm adding i agree with you at some
point you're gonna have to play e6 and
get the other bishop out
but we still seem to have a little bit
of time
don't tell i'm eddie i said hi yeah i
meant
chesponzo is here in person
so i wanna you're next i gotta see these
people that i've been talking to
for a year year and a half maybe yeah
yeah it's a longer trip for him
oh where is he germany oh oh he's awake
at that time in germany
i'm annie said hi why not bishops
theater guard upon well
you still want to keep this bishop
somewhat active because so
a very tiny but fun thing that people
usually forget is that
you don't just develop the bishops for
the sake of the bishop you develop them
for the sake of the rook that's stuck
behind them
so if your bishop could just stand c8
and your rook was still active
yeah sure why not your bishop is holding
the two different
diagonals it's not necessarily super but
it works so bishop on d7 if your rook
was like
more active i could go get behind bishop
on c8
yeah oh i'm manny thank you
yeah so knight f39 c6 makes the most
sense
why because yeah you're gonna have to
play e6 but at the same time
if you can choose between e6 or knight
c6 you know
for sure your knight's going to go to c6
you're never going to like do knight a6
or 97 in this position so might as well
do the knight c6
you might also give your opponent the
illusion that you want to do e5
you might want to do e5 but after castle
that kind of goes away because e5 now
there are
you know these super problems here that
you shouldn't have to deal with
you know pins are not fun yeah
but if for example instead of castling
let's see your opponent played
i'm going to do a weird move so we do a
weird move
now could you do e5 yeah i like it
we also have a different thread yeah i
mean again it's going to be isolated
pawns and still a lot of hassles but
it's worth it two bishops open center i
like it
all right so if castle not e5 is no
longer valid so we'll just go with e6
and get the other bishop in a good
position and here
arya played a novelty we're just on move
11
and this is a very normal position but
this is a novelty which is
very mind-blowing when you think about
how big
chess land is and
um from what my brother said
he assumed a lot and that aryan
tari had like prepared this before the
game
so do you think black or alireza is
going to get into
any trouble or is everything safe and
sound
uh troy boy it is live if you are
instead louis
run run make it here because then
they're gonna analyze your games
bring it in exactly bring a game
all right yeah so now
the big question oh the big question is
should we castle
well troy boy go play one go unleash us
play a bunch of games
save them up we usually have game
analysis
after this so that's the thing oh
careful because your knight is also
protecting over here and the rook is
also pinning so something like knight h5
does not
really work so
a lot of errors uh yeah knight h5
doesn't work queen d5 and this is just a
free pawn
so the options you have are between
castling
and honestly i'm not sure
maybe relocating at night somewhere that
i don't think that works
any magic either because
if you look at it from a different
perspective this queen over here what is
this queen doing
just attacking these two pawns right but
those of the those pawns are
long-term defended so bla white's queen
would
soon want to relocate somewhere else
anyway so if you play night day 5 and
you
push your knight to a not very pleasant
position then the queen can just go back
and that's also not something you didn't
do any harm to your opponent's position
so why would you do that
alrighty so
why not long cast though good question
chess bonzo do you want to take this one
why not line castle
i'm worried about the c file
clear point word about c file
on that side yeah aqua's already on this
side yeah um
i guess the other way to think about it
is
white yeah white's pieces are more ready
so white could simply just go like night
a tree
and it's trying to already create
some discomfort for our king
well not just looking for our pieces and
your pieces are just
very disorganized because you you're
gonna have to spend
next few moves figuring out how to
stabilize your queen side
while you do that uh white is just gonna
move the queen
start pushing pawns and you're not going
to get the chance to attack his
king side so yeah
long castle i wouldn't really recommend
it your king would still be weak
and there are no clear weaknesses now
i'm telling you why don't we like castle
what's wrong with castling
are we worried about take because if
tank will just take back
and there are no attacks currently
happening so i always have a 5
now i might even have e5 very cautious
about a5 though just saying
and i could just easily shift everything
the other side
oh kajinka how did you how do you know
uh sorry bj7 doesn't i also it's not
really
that optimal you just went bishop d6
like two moves ago
wait actually last move yeah you just
played bishop d6
literally right now bishop d6 why would
you come back that's
just yeah
castle link is indeed the best one and
taking is
not something to be concerned about it's
a bishop player your king is not that
weak it's just like
an opponent's king is also going to have
uh issues it's not like the key upon his
king is super safe as well
we can just work on the open g file
so in the game aryan just went for
knight d2
alright so now i think this is the first
critical position in the
game we have a decent middle game
and we have to decide between bunch of
plans and for me that has always been
the most
painful thing about chess just deciding
which
which which route route to take
and i i i see that there are a lot of
head noddings like ah
yes me too so
maybe h6 any
good uh cast i i don't well castel was a
novelty but
only because bishop g5 was a novelty so
after bishop g5 everyone after that's
going to be novelty
so
we have a very confident person in the
chat
it's good
pushing epon could be interesting but
if you're if you're uncomfortable with
the idea take then you should change
something about it
so what
was so let's just go one move back right
it's not
why couldn't we move this knight if we
move this slide this pawn would flow
right so can i move this knight now
i like the idea of doing stuff in the
queen side but first i think we need to
stabilize our king side a little and
this is kind of
funny because i think mimi
was the one who kept talking about
something in the g-file
and yeah that's
maybe later in few moves we can revisit
the g-pawn subject
so what do you guys think what should we
do now
yeah uh what about you
mister now or tracy anybody
i still can't decide it's okay
maybe
yeah the right idea and f6 yes i was
like worried about the knight getting
stuck but it won't get it can go right
yeah of course yeah knight h5 is the
best one
especially because if i get this knight
to f4 then there's going to be
different problems for your bishops you
have to choose between one of them
um so
white played queen d1 now
black to move what do we do knight f4 is
definitely something we should consider
but do we want naita for now or do we
want to
do some other move to provoke some of
white's pieces first
i give the move out
ah there was a concern about the move
g3 i really really want to take it
but i can also first attack this
you move it away
uh this night i need to stop protecting
i don't know if i
should take it let's see
i mean i know i have perpetual but i
don't know if i actually want
perpetual
i don't think our pieces are ready like
if my bishop could jump yeah i'd do it
but i don't
my my pieces are not ready and i'm sure
engine can find something with like
taking over here maybe the king moves
and move a bunch of knights around
see kenya i i but this is not human i
wouldn't do that
over the board because right now i feel
like this g3 is giving me a difference
weakness on f4
so this is i agree that g3 is a weakness
now
how can we attack it we don't want to
take it just yet
but how can we bring more pressure to it
yeah james you're correct f5
and you're going to continue with f4 and
the idea is that this is the weakness
we're going to
go poke at it eventually we're going to
eat it but we don't want to waste the
whole bishop on it
so that's why gt3 is not a good idea so
queen d1
i see a lot of f6 in the chat
uh what do we what do we think f6
yay nay oh thank you
ggr you should come visit
everybody should come visit
is this game from tata still no i think
this is
the norway yeah this is an rhs
i like f6 yeah exactly f6
it is and now the other question
are we ready for e5 keep thinking
why did white bring the queen back
yep exactly so tell me what's wrong with
e5
uh context knight takes
discovered just start with knight
if you take just now the queen takes
there's a nice checkmate thread
around here and this is another issue
yeah so you're not
ready for e5 just yet so let's go knight
f4
and now we are forcing
white to kind of deal with this knight
either you're gonna take it and give up
this bishop or you're gonna have to move
this bishop
which makes it even more unpleasant
bishop c2 is possible
but um it's you know your pieces are
very disorganized if you just have one
bishop here that looks good but it
doesn't have any support
i don't really see how that's beneficial
whereas
if you do the bishop of one you might be
able to do like g3
bishop g to relocate your pieces but
just looking at last three moves
you pushed your queen back then you
pushed your bishop back then you pushed
your other bishop back
so psychologically you're in a defensive
mode because you're just
putting everything back and back and
back and black is
a little attack over here a little
attack over here
just little by little
all right so black to move what do we
think we should do
what do you think we should do
my skin is glowing seriously
i started a new
sunscreen i don't usually do sunscreen
oh boy
it feels weird
so that's the thing are we ready for e5
just because we have two bishop doesn't
mean we should open up the center
keep in mind opponent also has two
bishops
whoa knight is tree sacrificed
not not not ready for it yet
oh moda i like what i see um
i would have to say a huge note to
knight takes h3 if you wanted to play a
chill move and just bring the other rook
to like
d8 or e8 that's perfectly fine too
but between something like e5
i'm a little skeptical on e5
does anybody want to tell me why i don't
like why e5 is not a good idea
so what do you guys think what's wrong
with e5
yeah exactly double pawn take
take now this is also a huge weakness
you also closed up your own
bishop that's just the definition of oh
boy no
yeah we don't want this now white is the
one who is
bringing back the attack
yeah no not not this all right so
we want to be able to take control of
our center but
not to not with this price all right so
nasa not to e5 that's a no to 93
that's a maybe to bring up your rock
what else do you got
um knight g6 like
i'm a little hesitant you still want e5
okay um
but maybe that's just stretching things
so what was the problem of e5 bishop
takes f4
so your solution is to move the knight
there is another option
instead of moving the knight
bring another defender for the knight
oh should we reroute
the other knight to g6 or
i think that's also possible but
yeah yeah so how do we feel about g5
take it let's take a second to look at
this how do we like this
okay there's a question what is that
knight doing on
f4 it's taking up space
is the knowing the opponent
no by opening the g file yeah yeah
opening a g-file is not a bad idea
ah smiley face also your pawns are
smiling apparently
i see that now okay that's another race
right yeah some good reason
all right so g5 what worries you the
most from white what do you think white
can do to that
kind of worries you
because if there's nothing that white
can do that worries you then you should
have done g5 five minutes ago
ah courage i assume that seems like the
chorus might be the issue
okay so i don't really see anything
um that's scary in the chat something
about h4 but
h4 what if i just do g4 and then
you gotta move this knight and then this
diagonal is mine and
no this is just too cool so what worries
you from g5
i'll try let me see how can i turn a
hint without giving a move
ah um so when we're doing like
uh king side or queen side attack we're
not talking in the center
we usually want the center to be closed
up because we don't want the opponent to
do anything in the center to us
having said that if now we are
doing something in the king side can the
opponent do anything in the center
yep c4 is the idea if you don't do c4
what else are you going to do
i mean yeah technically you could like
try for maybe b4 maybe
get their work here but my my ideas are
much more
dangerous than yours so you gotta do the
c4 you gotta create
some sort of um counter play and you
gotta make black
somewhat uncomfortable so let's continue
with the plans move the king along
let's just move the rook to this side
and here
white made a mistake white has a nice
opportunity for counter play in the
clean side
by like trying to push these pawns and
just
get something done on the clean side but
white messed up a little and white has a
strong grandmaster 26
plus so
white just took over here now we have to
decide do we want to take this with the
pawn or the bishop
it should be a relatively easy
choice um i'm on my pick for the world
cup
i live in san luis there are three
people who live in san luis that are
playing there
so for women's world cup my pick is the
star rula because she's my roommates
if i say anything else i don't think
she'll let me live
for next year um but my pick for
mail i would say
it's between fabi dominguez
or the newest edition of saint louis or
onion
one of these three
whoever wins i'll be happy as long as
it's one of these three
is he living here yet i'm
not sure i mean their super tournament
is going to start soon so it makes the
most sense that he would move around
that time
so
oh we got someone rooting for anish
interesting
very strong oh i think he's having a
second baby soon
why do i know this stuff
i like babies they're tiny and cute
when they're not mine alright so which
one are we gonna take this with
i kind of agree taking a bishop makes
the most sense because if you're going
to take with the pawn then what are you
going to do with your bishop
right so take i mean again there's like
a trade-off if you take with the pawn
you have the
this um file opening up and you could
consider getting this bishop active
but it means that this bishop will be
blind so i kind of like taking
the other bishop and
yeah that's what i thought like probably
more like um
intermediate people uh players would
prefer to take with the pawn because the
op immediately open up the g
file but that's not that shouldn't
be the concern because then now the king
can just move and even if you try to
double up
your pawns are ugly your opponent gets a
lot of
new ideas and i don't like happy
opponents
seriously i don't all right so we take
with bishop
pawn jumps now what do we do this move
had me a little tripping
i'm not entirely it's not the first move
i thought about
but it makes perfect sense the first
move i want to do is i want to eat the
pond but we can't really do that
because then attacking my queen and then
i gotta move the clean and
white pieces it gets active pretty
instantly
so we don't want to take that just yet
but we know why don't we want to take it
we don't want to take it because this
pawn will fall
so how can i try to
um avoid that
we identified the problem now what's the
solution
while you guys think i'm gonna share a
little bit of a story
about um when i just remember this that
one of the things
i was i was so excited about like chess
going back to in person
and then i remembered one of the things
that i
hated when i was playing chess was the
sound of people's shoes
when i'm like deep in concentration as
somebody who's like wearing other like
sneakers and the sounds like creek how
they say like creeky
or like yeah squeaky or like heels and
tuck tuck
yes something like that no like that's
that like a little bit of that is fine
but
yeah i just yeah i started thinking
about
how cool it will be chess is going back
to in person again and
yeah what else was this
yeah i always had like these one or two
opponents who like
dropped their pants super loud like bang
the clock too
and i learned that if i bang it harder
they'll stop doing it but
yeah not my most favorite oh
coughing i mean yeah that's also when
you're
yeah when you're like in deep focus any
kind of sound just makes you want to
punch stuff
so i guess that's why they always make
it like the air conditioner going super
loud
anyways
all right so what do you think yeah okay
so i see a lot of like
b5 ideas imani you are correct
uh
no you can't have any kind of
electronics airpods or
otherwise actually i don't know if
you're
like a cochlear implant i don't know
about that but that would be tricky i've
actually never had to deal with a case
like that
but that's the question for arbiter if
you have like a cochlear implant because
that's a medical device
but i don't know all right uh what do
you think
black should do so we took a tiny break
talking about
tournament in person what do you think
black should do now
we i mean we eventually want to be able
to do g4 and stuff
but yeah we're going to move the queen
because the queen is the problem right
because the rook is in front of my queen
so let's move this queen
yeah this wasn't the first one that i
considered but kind of
got there so queen d6 b5 let's move this
knight and
c5 was another inaccuracy um
c5 doesn't feel like an accuracy it's
like one of those weird moves that
you you think it can't be
wrong because you're advancing your
pawns you're taking up space you're
actually
making something out of the queen side
but the problem is you also close up the
center the center is no longer
um a problem for black so now i can
focus on your king side
better after i save my queen so instead
of c5
i'll give you guys 30 seconds what do
you think is a better move
if not c5
[Music]
that door is never open
to make sure that door is never open
but i've never seen that door open ever
when
random times okay
um not necessarily cd5 is also quite
early because you just take with the
pawn there is no real threat so you just
open up opponents bishop
we want to keep the tension we don't
want to resolve it
a4 i think a4 is actually interesting
but then what do you do after g4
yeah i don't really like letting my
opponent just
ride on the king side so what else
how about white plays g4
uh
what if i just play like h5 no something
like that doesn't really work you can't
just
when your king is under attack you you
need to have more pieces to defend you
you shouldn't help your opponent to open
it up
so your game is in the queen side you
have advantage on the queen side
but how can you use the space that
you've gained in the queen side to help
cover up some of your king side
rook e2 interesting but no
the other problem is this pin so
yes yes yes yeah rock c3 makes the most
sense
and it's not like white's having
advantage but white is kind of getting
some space back and resolving some of
the threats
now if you try to play g4 boom boom now
you can even cancel something
cool like 95 because now this is a
this is a threat and
um yeah so this is something that black
still has advantage
but white has a better fight white has
more chances
and like for example right now but chevy
one will
white will win can you tell me how will
white win here if bishop
won bishop one is a terrible mistake
but
seven uh
yeah i mean the gaining space part is a
huge
part in chess
because without space you can't really
do anything with your pieces
queen h4 um no because not quite ashore
you have to deal with i'll give up this
bishop
and then i'll throw in some checks and
i'll save it you have to be very
accurate with your movement here
why black just made a terrible mistake
how can white use it
no the stroke giving up makes no sense
you literally have
two pieces left you gotta be way more
careful
what else we gotta so take we gotta
you're correct about wanting to bring in
a queen just where
the idea of bishop d3 looks interesting
what if i just do knight f5 to cover up
now black is winning
queen h yeah exactly queen h5 nice
and now if you try to run i'll take and
now c5
to just take kick your queen away and
this is just this this
like if you agree to this position you
know you're winning
you shouldn't have to worry about too
much this is actually checkmate in
three moves
you you don't have to see it here and
when you play quinnish five but
when you play queen h5 if
you see queen h5 if you consider check
okay i don't have to take it
but i can because now even if you do the
trick effect there is no recap seven
compared to if you played queenish for
and then there was rickish that rook f7
right
so we gotta be very careful and accurate
about these moves
anyhoo let's go back back back what c 33
my point in rook c3 would y
give white the best chance so white
played c5 and move this away and white
played g3 which was another
just like inaccuracy and i don't
necessarily
understand it's like you're daring
opponents to want to do stuff to your
king side
i mean i understand it's a very pleasant
position but something maybe like rookie
2 or again maybe rook c3 just try to
get your rooks a little more involved
because something like g3
now what do we do after this the game is
kind of already decided you just have to
play accuracy
the the yeah the
uh the main thing to know is should i
take
does this work
i i don't think it's the right time
even if it works it's not as pleasant as
we want
it to be because now white gets to
cover up the king with too many little
things
and that's not what we want
not the right time even if we take it's
better to play g4 now
but if you're gonna play g4 just do it
now
yeah g4 take
and if you take over here that's just
purely
oops because we just take with the queen
and if you try to cover up that's not
going to work even g3 looks pretty
enough
and we take over there there's one
checkmate looking nice
the knight can come over give another
checkmate this is just
pick and choose which piece should make
studio should mate you
basically all right um so g4
take take now this picture is also safe
for
the time being bishop h3
now uh what do we do now again it's
important to decide
is it time to take over here or do i
still need
more pieces
pawn mates so one thing probably will
take me much longer
i agree it's not the right time so let's
bring the rook back
i will double up and i will reorganize
my pieces to your king soon enough
uh knight f1 could also be interesting
but you just
drop the rook so that's another reason
why having the rook
not under pin would be a better idea so
here after king h1 first round made
another an
end inaccuracy
the better move here would be finally
bishop g3
take we take with the queen and we bring
the other knights
this would actually work pretty nicely
um
it has a very nice attack it's not
winning winning but it has clear
advantage
because if you try to take well that's
just going to be fun checkmate
if you don't try to take then i can just
do quinash four
bring this knight black has a lot of
opportunities for different attacks
so bishop g3 was finally the right time
to do it
but he missed it he played e5
which still holds a lot of advantage but
a little questionable keep in mind
taking over here does not work simply
because you
your other bishop is dropping so take
take and here aryan just want
knight edge too makes sense because you
can't take
queen h3 would be quite at the end of
the game
literally like knight h2 actually let me
just
show it there we go
so uh knight is two first we still do
the same thing to avoid
take we still want to get checkmate rook
g1
now what do we do
now this take could be a problem
so do we move the bishop or what
seven um could you rephrase the question
i'm a little confused
yeah bring up the other rook lovely now
if you take over here well this rook g2
knight over here i can't even just play
e4
this is way too much pressure white is
like
almost check me like two moves three
moves this is not gonna hold
um was that also good
no no uh oh i mean possible
yeah i think that's also i mean you
there wouldn't be more any checkmates
but
yeah you can also take eat over here and
it's just a queen versus two pieces
this is this should be good enough for
wind but that's just more
powerful so queenie 2
was played in the game i don't get queen
e2 but
there's a lot of back and forth moves in
this position that i was just
a little ha so what do we do
try to try to figure out what does
white want because if we can figure out
what does the opponent want then we can
block it
ah seven yeah that's something that you
should everybody should
be more comfortable with easy basic
checkmate patterns
because if you miss them then your game
can that could be
the difference between winning or not
happened to me
once or twice even when i was 2400
there was a very nice checkmate idea and
about the
long diagonal and it will always haunt
me it was the last round i was tired i
just wanted to get out of there a little
and i was playing in the grandmaster and
i had such a beautiful position
i believe i've shown that game somewhere
in our youtube channel
but yeah
yeah so opponent wants to get something
to f3 so let's go e4
exactly take away any possibility for
any any defense
so rook c3 now let's bring the last
piece that's not working
it's not like you're going to take over
here because well that'll be fun
checkmate
so now um the white just took over here
which i'm not so sure why but then again
this is such a
sad position for white i don't think
it's honestly
um is going to last that long so
now what do we do again if you
just honestly if you i'm kind of curious
if you just wanted to like
chill with the bishop back here you
would still have
decent advantage so you don't have to do
crazy stuff right now
but what do you think is the best move
in the position
it's funny my brother did this game so
he wrote the
commentary for this and he has a very
aggressive comment here
i don't know if i should say it
so what do you think something about no
more oxygen
left on white's lungs this is a little
too dark
so what do we think almost done yeah i
take on g3
yep
and you can't really do much because
that'll be
too pretty and you
could do like rook g2 but
then what how how are you gonna defend
after here
so now there's a new weakness your back
rank
how can white how can black use the
weak back rank
um yeah rookie seven so there's a
question on if you're just
continuing kara's light are you just
like praying for a blunder
not necessarily it could also simply be
like you're in disbelief that you got
whooped so bad so fast
it has happened before you just continue
because you don't realize how bad your
position is and you're always hoping
can't be that bad right you just like
i'm not like
i don't feel that lost i still have some
game but
i mean it's really hard to be objective
when the position is this
um this bad
yeah sorry 7 makes the most sense queen
bee won and then
now what do we do this is such a here
this is the last one of the game
and it's so fun what do you guys think
knight h4 i'm sure that also works
but yeah actually knight h4 i'm a little
worried about rock takes g3
careful with that
oops i mean knight dashboard would be
nice
but so what is our main checkmate idea
right now
a lot of these moves that i'm saying
could work oh maybe not bishop of two
you're gonna
lose their queen over here as long as
you don't blunder
a lot of these moves that i suggest that
could work
but what do you think is the main
checkmate
what's the easiest checkmate pattern
that you can see here
nobody
so what was our idea here why did we
play your key seven
background checkmate right so white is
defending it
now how do we
all together is bring a little bit more
yep yep yep turkey and voila
yeah so white resigned here i guess you
can't really stop rookie one
i mean technically you could take over
here i'll give you that check
you can go back and then i can take it
over here you take there and i take
there
whoa maybe that's what they were hoping
for
and then like tag over here and this is
just
it's too painful it's like a full rook
at this point all right
well yeah that's all i had
for today can you tell us about your
book
oh yes so uh thanks
so my brother and i wrote this book
called
well the name kept changing but the
basic idea is that it's gonna
teach you how to the tips and tricks no
thank you
and how to unbalance your opponent and
we thought the royal jungle would be fun
your jungle guide which is also royal
because the peach is also there fishy
so uh we we wrote this over quarantine
and it's uh it's an actually it's kind
of in print now
so yeah it'll be out by
end of the month first week of august so
yeah
make sure to look out for it the
thinking publisher did a
great job just creating this they drew
it they
they even surprised me with the kitty on
it and there will be another surprise in
there too
it's persian food there'll be some nice
recipes some cool pictures
yeah exactly gm gm judging
our game all right yeah so that's it
i hope you guys enjoy it it's um a lot
of our personal games and it's kind of
it's a
the we wrote it with the hope of giving
more attention and
the chess world by kind of giving some
hope to the lower rated to
you can be tired too so yeah
i will see you guys next time thank you
[Music]
you